let's go next to our caller from the two
five six area code who's calling today
from two five six this is out how we go
ma'am hey Alex what's up not much man uh
big fan of your show
I appreciate what you do Thank You there
so uh but I just wanted to get your
opinion free education
I live in Huntsville and it's a military
town it's got the Redstone Arsenal
employs many people but up just is on my
mind like how do you think that would
affect military enrollment I know that
some people do it for love a country but
nowadays people do it or so for I feel
like for the incentives you know as far
as education health care so I wanted to
get your opinion on that yeah I have a
segment about this it's called something
like wouldn't free college and health
care decimate military recruiting or
something like that and it's certainly
plausible that military recruiting would
be affected if the economic incentives
are the reason that a lot of people are
joining there are questions as to what
percentage of people who join the
military are actually joining for those
reasons but here's the the big argument
for me I want people in the military who
actually want to be in the military I
don't want someone joining the military
out of desperation because they need
health care so I actually think that
it's right absolutely and I think even
if it's true
I don't think we are well served by
having people in the military who don't
actually want to be there except that
it's how they figured out right afford
college and get health care so if it's
true I don't think it's a bad thing
the military is more than big enough
right and one more thing I have a
recommendation if again getting ahead of
myself but if Bernie Sanders wins
crystal ball man
she needs to be a press secretary okay
all right maybe that I'll ask her about
that I'm in touch with crystal we'll see
we'll see about that that would be very
interesting all right thank you for the
call very much appreciate hearing from
you